a partir de ahora se envía a la cámara
de diputados y diputadas muchas gracias
el aborto y el matrimonio y adopción por
parte de parejas del mismo sexo dos
temas que contribuyeron a la
polarización reflejada en las elecciones
del domingo en chile el proyecto de ley
de interrupción voluntaria del embarazo'
legalizaría el mismo hasta la semana 14
de gestación tanto para la mujer como
para el médico que realice el
procedimiento
en chile se permite el aborto por
violación peligro de la vida de la madre
e inviabilidad del feto pero interrumpir
la gestación más allá de los tres meses
y medio seguiría siendo ilegal y una
mujer podría enfrentar hasta cinco años
de cárcel por practicarse pero hoy es un
tema de derecho humano es un tema serio
pero en términos estrictos aquí hay una
parte de la derecha que sigue siendo
grave en nadie en cuanto al proyecto
sobre matrimonio igualitario y la
adopción por parte de parejas
homosexuales fue enviada al legislativo
por la ex presidenta michelle bachelet
siete meses antes de concluir su mandato
en 2018 pero el proceso de votación no
avanzó con la llegada del
centroderechista sebastián piñera al
poder y su inesperado apoyo a la unión
de parejas del mismo sexo
el proyecto fue priorizado esta
iniciativa no es un proyecto valórico
este es un proyecto en materia de
derechos humanos
y como aquí se ha señalado los derechos
humanos no se defienden
dependiendo si es que me acomoda o no
los derechos humanos se defienden con
convicción el candidato ultraconservador
que obtuvo la mayoría de votos en las
presidenciales del domingo rechaza
abiertamente el aborto y el matrimonio
igualitario y ha prometido revertirlo
mientras que javier boris lo apoya